yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah but later I had a wrong setup will
you look very weird no it's ok it's made
me take a while him to play the first
couple of moves ok I play the Alekhine's
defense and my opponent here Bullock is
going for 493 which is one of the
critical moves maybe the most critical
move ok and this this is this is the
best line
oh it's really a long time since I had a
look at this I think you go to f5
what happened laughter g-form really not
certain
g4 do you go to g6 then e six there's
s6m and this is the desert tough opening
yeah here you you take with the with the
bishop I think you could stick with the
pawn and it doesn't I don't know I just
don't remember I've looked at this some
bits one year gone but so I just briefly
you know and it's it's a little bit all
yeah that chief natural is a critical
move
[Music]
I'd love to play this but I cannot allow
him to take one t7 only 60 just like
that
if I go five now I could try to return
the pawn I would definitely be fine if
he would take it like he five Bishop d7
Queen takes d5 d5 would be definitely
okay for me yeah I think I should go age
five at night now Knight f6 you can play
that try to return it like that but yeah
here white has to think about this very
hard if he wants to take the pawn back
one play something else something else
could be just a developing move like a
Knight to c3 for example yeah he goes
for it
it's probably the correct decision you
know I wonder if I should keep on f6
that could be far too risky honestly but
yeah it's kind of the only move that
makes sense in this position a bit okay
if I can get a 5 in without direct
punishment I would be fine not tough
okay I mean if you play a slightly risky
opening this is what you have to kind of
live with in a way that things can be
tricky to play yeah okay but that this
this could have been worse I feel when
d7 and I'm pushing this back now the
rook has to return basically I don't see
anything else
Queenie three years
it's not working you two king of seven
and the rookies strapped and exchanging
you lose the exchange but not an issue I
think you should just go back and then I
have e5 and maybe if maybe maybe I get
to cast off but unsure what he's
thinking about yeah you have to go back
basically I don't see anything else what
there is something creative yeah but
does that work I mean D 5 D 5 Queen e2
king f7 rook moves and then I'll play
500
it's okay king of seven and now I look
III as mandatory on all this one yeah
and here I've got is six Bishop e6 but
Ruby 3 I wouldn't have played d4 but
also just a 5
yeah so Bishop to d6 is looking very
normal
my take it King King takes that an issue
[Music]
we're asking I can even take with the
pawn so not a big deal
I should be totally saved them
should be safe in the center yeah I
think yeah let's go here
rookie 1/5 there's no f/4g to Bishop c5
and if I get in Queen G form and trains
Queens are traded and then it's
basically over
right now and at one point I am able to
play deform and now just this yeah the
porn and the better minor piece plus the
cling should be plenty
mmm okay I can take but let's just go go
for the points it's actually easier okay
so let's have a look there I mean I'm
fairly certain the opening yes can we
improve them I really don't remember I
think Bishop f5 is right I don't think
this is wrong here and then maybe FTX
and then the F takes e6 the engine gives
FTX you six-foot
both G point we should default scary to
me and like this but maybe this is not
such an issue you know it's just a very
weird position it's probably okay
neither Vader gave eight it's no problem
at all
now I taught the same I took with the
with the minor piece and we had to trade
and Bishop g4 and the engine likes white
which is not a surprise I think it
should be a better position for white
castle's 97 rook e1 and now I decided to
go for each 5f and you know I think
getting the pawn back is completely
uncritical this this is this must be
okay the only way this could not be okay
is white having he six technically but I
don't think he has and he's not for an
advantage I mean I saw this and I didn't
think that would kill me they are
probably right in that assumption the
engine gives equal you know their white
cab it clearly has compensation but I
don't think it it should tell me and
what does the computer want to do c3
Bishop g5 things like that mm yeah maybe
that is more precise I mean this keeps a
pawn on d4 which in itself is quite
useful I could try this I like this
engine suggestion intending a form and
if he's getting the pawn back I think I
could be okay that looks like a very
decent range structure
engine still likes white and the night
on c7 is purely defensive you know it's
not great
maybe you don't have great yeah I'm just
saying it's not to not to not fantastic
okay the compare my opponent played 93
and to take take 9 f6 and Here I am I
kind of suspected that Bishop e6 cannot
be the the answer 94 is cool yeah I
basically have to yeah watch is what has
a an excellent initiative here even here
you have to go to d7 and that helps me
definitely
yeah that it switches to an advantage
immediately as the engine yeah yeah I
was thinking look III ago ago e5 and I
should be okay and Queen f3 King f7
there is no square
yeah and here this is this is helpful
yeah I get all those helpful moves again
this I would have played each five yeah
which the engine confirms this is
strongest because if the rook takes I
mean it's a desiring to move anyway and
if the rook takes we should be six I
thought it should be fantastic I mean
something like that is really not great
now like here and the Queen oh sorry
the Queen takes got this and now thinks
I'm more or less over don't don't think
that's anything happening that can
disturb me maybe I could have played d4
but but is such a if you get quince
traded that is basically the end of the
game another fantastic Center and the
bishop supporting it with the King it's
it's winning easily
it's a risky opening it really is thanks
a lot for watching